On the 29th of January, 1999, best friends Laura Bible and Ashley Freeman had a sleepover at Ashley's house to celebrate her 16th birthday. Ashley's parents, Danny and Kathy Freeman were also at the house, located in Craig County, Oklahoma. About 6 a.m. the next morning, a neighbour reported that the Freeman house was on fire. Emergency services rushed to the scene and found the bodies of Kathy and Danny Freeman. However, Laura and Ashley were nowhere to be found. We covered this story very early on, way back in Case 3. All sorts of theories have emerged over the years. There was speculation Ashley and Laura might have murdered Danny and Kathy themselves. There were rumours that Danny was involved in drugs.
1999年1月29日，好朋友劳拉·拜布尔和阿什利·弗里曼在阿什利家过夜，庆祝她16岁生日。阿什利的父母丹尼和凯茜·弗里曼也在位于俄克拉何马州克雷格县的房子里。第二天早上6点左右，邻居报警称弗里曼家着火了。紧急服务人员赶到现场，发现了凯茜和丹尼·弗里曼的尸体。然而，劳拉和阿什利却不见踪影。我们在案情回顾第3期很早就报道了这个故事。多年来涌现出各种各样的猜测。有推测称阿什利和劳拉可能亲手谋杀丹尼和凯茜。还有传言称丹尼涉嫌毒品。
Two different convicted murderers confessed to killing Laura and Ashley, only to later recant their confessions. The cases remained unsolved for all of these years. Until now. Good afternoon. I'm Craig County District Attorney Matt Ballard. For 18 years, the community in Craig County, including many members of the media, have followed the case of the deaths of Danny and Kathy Freeman, the mysterious disappearance of their 16-year-old daughter, Ashley Freeman, and Ashley's friend, 16-year-old Laura Bible and the arson of the Freeman family home. Yesterday, there was an arrest in the case. OSBI Investigator Tammy Ferrari and my SVU
两名不同的被定罪杀人犯承认杀害了劳拉和阿什利，但后来又翻供。多年来，这些案件一直未破。直到现在。大家下午好。我是克雷格县地方检察官马特·巴拉德。18年来，克雷格县的社区，包括许多媒体成员，一直关注着丹尼和凯茜·弗里曼夫妇遇害案、他们16岁的女儿阿什利·弗里曼及其朋友、16岁的劳拉·拜布尔神秘失踪案，以及弗里曼家族住宅纵火案。昨天，此案有了逮捕行动。俄克拉何马州调查局（OSBI）调查员塔米·费拉里和我的性犯罪特别调查组（SVU）
Investigator Gary Stansel, through incredible police work, identified three perpetrators, two of whom have since died since the beginning of the investigation. Today, charges were filed against Ronnie Dean Busick, who by law is presumed innocent of the charges. Mr. Busick is charged with acting in concert with two other men as follows. Four counts of first-degree murder for killing Kathy Freeman, Danny Freeman, Ashley Freeman, and Laura Bible. Two counts of kidnapping for the abductions of Ashley Freeman and Laura Bible, and a final count of first-degree arson for setting fire to the Freeman home. The other two perpetrators identified during the most recent course of the investigation are
调查员加里·斯坦塞尔通过出色的警务工作，确定了三名嫌疑人，其中两人自调查开始以来已经去世。今天，罗尼·迪恩·布西克被正式起诉，根据法律规定，他被推定为无罪。布西克先生被指控与另外两名男子共同实施以下犯罪：四项一级谋杀罪，分别杀害了凯茜·弗里曼、丹尼·弗里曼、阿什利·弗里曼和劳拉·拜布尔；两项绑架罪，绑架了阿什利·弗里曼和劳拉·拜布尔；以及一项最终的一级纵火罪，纵火焚烧了弗里曼的家。在最近的调查过程中确定的另外两名嫌疑人是
Warren Philip Welch II, more commonly known as Phil Welch, and David A. Pennington. Again, Mr. Welch and Mr. Pennington died during the course of this investigation. Members of Ashley and Laura's families were briefed this morning regarding the arrest, charges, and details brought to light by investigators Ferrari and Stansel. Here again, I want to extend my condolences to the girls' families. They've learned these young ladies' final days were certainly horrific, and today's announcement no doubt comes as little solace to their grief. We're standing together, releasing this statement, however, because we believe there are people with
沃伦·菲利普·韦尔奇二世（通常被称为菲尔·韦尔奇）和大卫·A·彭宁顿。同样，韦尔奇先生和彭宁顿先生在本次调查期间已经去世。今天上午，调查员费拉里和斯坦塞尔向阿什利和劳拉家属通报了有关逮捕、指控和调查细节。在此，我再次向女孩们的家属表示哀悼。他们得知这些年轻女孩的最后日子无疑是极其可怕的，今天的宣布对她们的悲伤来说无疑是杯水车薪。然而，我们站在一起发表这份声明，是因为我们相信有人
knowledge of this crime who can assist in recovering the girls' bodies and bring some closure to the families. Asset forth in the affidavit for arrest warrant, Phil Welch, Dave Pennington, and Ronnie Busick killed Mr. and Mrs. Freeman, abducted the teenage girls, and set fire to the Freeman home. Information is also filed with the affidavit, revealing the girls were kept alive for an unknown number of days following the fire. That polaroid photographs of the girls in their final days were seen by multiple people, and Welch, Pennington, and Busick made many statements to multiple people about the crimes during their lives. Although the criminal case against Mr. Busick has commenced, we must stay focused on the recovery of Ashley and Laura for the sake
掌握着这起犯罪的知情权，他们可以协助找回女孩们的尸体，并为家属带来一些心理上的慰藉。正如逮捕令宣誓书中所述，菲尔·韦尔奇、戴夫·彭宁顿和罗尼·布西克杀害了弗里曼夫妇，绑架了这些十几岁的女孩，并放火烧毁了弗里曼的家。宣誓书中还披露了相关信息，显示女孩们在火灾后还活了不知多少天。多名目击者曾看到女孩们在最后日子的宝丽来照片，并且韦尔奇、彭宁顿和布西克在生前曾向多个人发表过关于这些罪行的多次言论。尽管针对布西克先生的刑事案件已经启动，但为了家属和我们整个社区的利益
of the families and our entire community. The following is from an article on fox23.com, quote, An affidavit claimed to Welch kept photos in a leather briefcase that showed the girls bound and gagged at his home during their last days. According to the affidavit, multiple people said they had seen the pictures, but the suspects reportedly threatened them. The affidavit claimed the girls were tied up, drugged, and raped before they were killed. According to fox23.com, the affidavit allegedly goes on to say that Welch, Pennington, and Busick had implied to others that the Freeman parents had been murdered over a debt and that Laura and Ashley had entered a room where
我们必须继续集中精力寻找阿什利和劳拉。以下内容摘自fox23.com上的一篇文章，引述如下：“宣誓书声称韦尔奇在一个皮质公文包里保存着照片，显示女孩们在他家度过最后日子时被捆绑和封口。”根据宣誓书，多个人表示他们看过这些照片，但嫌疑人据称威胁了他们。宣誓书声称女孩们在被杀害前遭到捆绑、下药和强奸。据fox23.com报道，宣誓书据称还指出，韦尔奇、彭宁顿和布西克曾向其他人暗示，弗里曼父母是因为债务而被谋杀的，劳拉和阿什利在案发当晚曾走进一个房间，当时弗里曼父母正在买毒品。
the Freeman parents were buying drugs on the night of the crime. The suspects had threatened the lives of people who may have had information about the crimes, which is why they didn't come forward over the years. Investigators don't know how long the girls were kept alive after they were kidnapped. Investigators still need people to come forward with information about where the girls' bodies may be. Anyone with information is urged to contact the Oklahoma State Bureau of Investigation at 1-800-522-8017 or via email at the following address tips at osbi.ok.gov. A private reward of $50,000 still stands for information regarding the location of the girls. I do feel like the investigators are saying there are people out there over this process
嫌疑人曾威胁那些可能掌握犯罪信息的人的生命，这就是为什么他们多年来一直没有站出来。调查人员不知道女孩们被绑架后活了多久。调查人员仍然需要知情者提供有关女孩尸体可能藏匿地点的线索。敦促任何掌握信息的人拨打1-800-522-8017联系俄克拉何马州调查局，或通过以下电子邮箱地址发送电子邮件：tips@osbi.ok.gov。关于女孩下落的信息，目前仍悬赏5,0000美元的私人奖金。我确实觉得调查人员在整个过程中表示，有些人因为担心自己的生命安全而害怕开口
that are afraid to talk because they're fearful for their life. You know, they can remain anonymous, they can make calls and talk and say, we really think you need to do this, or back when. In 2015, I took a different approach to trying to find my daughter and I started using the online media, which really sparked where we are today in three years. Because it wasn't the older generation, it was their children and grandchildren that says, I might know something. And it's due to their efforts coming out that we're able to move forward. But there are people out there, I still feel in my heart that they know something. However, little it might be to them, it's like a puzzle piece. But somebody knows where these girls are. And for me, I need to bring my daughter home.
你知道的，他们可以保持匿名，他们可以打电话交谈并说：“我们真的认为你们需要这样做”或者回到过去。2015年，我采取了不同的方法来寻找我的女儿，我开始使用网络媒体，这真正引发了我们在三年后所处的位置。因为不是老一代，而是他们的孩子和孙辈说，我可能知道一些事情。正是由于他们挺身而出的努力，我们才能够继续前进。但外面还有人，我内心深处依然觉得他们知道些什么。对他们来说可能微不足道，就像拼图的一小块。但有人知道这些女孩在哪里。对我来说，我需要把我的女儿带回家。
I want to just say to our greatest and deepest thanks to Gary Stansel and Mrs. Varar for their work and involvement in this case because it was a wild mess before they became involved to all these years. And the first 15 years seemed like it was fruitless. Very little bit of information and evidence ever came forward. But through the last three years, the Lord has answered a lot of prayers for us. And we just want to thank the law enforcement community, not just the DA's office and OSBI, but Craig County Sheriff's Department, all the sheriff departments and law enforcement agencies that we've dealt with through the years in Kansas too. And around the area, all the different areas. I know I'm probably forgetting someone, but I just want to thank them
我要向加里·斯坦塞尔和夫人瓦拉尔对本案的工作和参与表示最深切的感谢，因为在他们介入之前，这里一团糟，而且已经持续了这么多年。前15年似乎毫无结果。很少有信息和证据浮出水面。但在过去的三年里，上帝为我们回答了许多祈祷。我们只想感谢执法界，不仅是地方检察官办公室和俄克拉何马州调查局，还有克雷格县警长办公室、我们多年来打过交道的堪萨斯州以及该地区所有警长办公室和执法机构。我知道我可能漏掉了一些人，但我只想感谢他们
all for their participation and help in this case. We've missed her for a long time. But we're going to bring her home and we're going to hold on to that. Thank you all very much. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所有人对本案的参与和帮助。我们想念她很久了。但我们要把她带回家，并且我们会坚持到底。非常感谢大家。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。